hi guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to king k
beezy featuring polo g
book bag 2.0 i don't know i don't know
if you want me to keep doing this series
don't forget to comment like subscribe
please subscribe i'm trying to move out
of my parents house eventually
at some point and yeah i'm gonna start
the video
[Music]
[ __ ] and get killed with your [ __ ] ass
little bro got blood on the shirt with
this [ __ ] ass go right at this get
murphy
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] imma start i might burst
with my stiff ass hop out the car like
who wanted
i have no idea what he just said like at
all like not even a little bit
i heard that i'm a star are you standing
on a table right now oh no
i was gone when they did that panda and
the rat with my chrome and my wig at if
he won't be hit his home with a big mac
[ __ ] be breaking the code like a
kitkat running your mouth like a hogan
okay okay so he's saying like people
break the code like i think there's like
a code like you're not supposed to
snitch
and i think like that's what he's saying
like no snitching
because he said something about like
i don't know anything so i'm thinking
like and someone broke a code
so i think it's like he snitched or
someone snitched maybe you're running
your mouth like a hoe get you [ __ ]
everyone running your mouth like a hoe
gets you spit slapped
like i don't really care if people talk
[ __ ] like just keep
keep on going you know keep keep moving
on i don't
get wrapped up i can make full blunts
out of [ __ ] like huh i'm rolling
backwards what the [ __ ] is it
my coop automatic like [ __ ] is the
clutch and you still rocking packs i
brought you a bunk could have bought a
new gun what i spent on my charm i get
cheese by the pound this is not parmesan
i'm smoking broccoli counting up lettuce
in love with the glock i think i got a
fetish crush in my pocket
he smokes sweet he smokes weed that's
what i got from that season my
a pipe in the back of the fur thinking
this we can turn matters to worse go
from cadillac trucks to a cadillac
hearse
act like you pop and get popped like a
purse run like he got it we robbed him
okay he said a lot of words really fast
so i'm trying to like
keep up his girlfriend has to be pretty
and she also has to smoke weed
and he talked about having guns like i
know there was more but like sometimes i
just can't process it that fast
go through his wallet and all of his
merch [ __ ] what you call it i'll call it
some work and i'm constantly bawling
like cars laverne i ain't [ __ ] her
okay i got it he said i'm not f in her
raw which just means
like he he's gonna wear a condom he's
gonna use protection
[Music]
all of my little [ __ ] earthquake gang
cause they trying to make some shake off
a [ __ ] i'm from up north dropping race
with the hitters hey listen to feel like
we played for the stellar
back in the day i snooze off the drink
double cover with the game dropping
eight in the picture
come on the block when we passed around
heard you loving that horn you
faithfully
he said something with like like this
guy's
girl is like going around like they're
passing her around
and he's like kind of bragging he's like
you like she faithfully kisses you but
we pass her around we all get her
that that's what i got through the city
they speak of my name but that's only a
substance i'll go back avalon i used to
post up out west off the x looking ugly
[Music]
ain't no question my little boy dog he
only [ __ ] on the floor when he dumping
might make the news or something for
thinking [ __ ] sweet caught a shot to the
face nice
i don't got a pencil opinion this is
like the most confused like i
literally have been from video this is
what i got
from it this is what i got from it like
can i listen to it again oh it's my
channel i can do what i want i'm going
to listen to that part again
yeah i forget this is my channel i can
do whatever i want
hatefully kissing they know my [ __ ]
ringing all through the city they speak
of my name but that's only a substance i
go back capitola i used to post up out
west off the x looking ugly or something
freelance cause [ __ ] [ __ ] know how my
brothers was coming ball like i'm in i'm
shooting like living and i'm just gonna
do it like dirt when i'm stunning
okay i don't know what empty like dumb
clips
means like i don't i seriously like
don't know what that means
uh wait oh i bet it's something with
guns like a clip
for a gun and he's also saying that his
homeboy is cool because
he's like i'm going to do it like him
i'm going to keep going i'm going to
keep going though
he wanted uh blow this for oh like a
trumpet ain't no question my little boy
dog he gonna leave [ __ ] on the floor
when he dump it
might make the news or something for
thinking [ __ ] sweet caught a shot to the
face nice skunk
i don't got a pencil a pen in his book
bag add a like tan to the clip cause
it'll look bad don't give a [ __ ] with
you piss [ __ ] get mad or you can [ __ ]
and get killed with your [ __ ] ass
libero got blood on the shirt with this
[ __ ] ass go right at this get murked up
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] imma start my burst with
my stiff ass hop out the car like who
want it
they're really good for each other like
they hype each other up like they're
both like he's cool
another guy's like he's cool and they're
both like we're cool together
i don't know if he won't be hitting home
with a big mac [ __ ] be breaking the
code like a kitkat running your mouth
like a hogan who [ __ ]
back to the don't run your like no
snitching we're back to that
all right guys i learned a lot today i
think i'm getting cooler and cooler
every single day
so thanks for coming along in this
journey with me
don't forget like comment subscribe
tell me was it close did i get it am i
getting cooler
let me know and comment what video i
should do next talk to you later bye
guys